Three of these solutions won't work already for the reason that they would lead
to an increase in temperature even though the forest is warmer than the ambient temperature.
With this solution, the rate of change of our temperature would always be positive.
That doesn't look like heat loss. The same happens here.
If the temperature of our forest is larger than the ambient temperature,
we again get a positive rate of change here.
This does not make sense. This is the right one. Think about two compartments.
We have one compartment with temperature capital T
and another compartment with a temperature of 300 K.
The difference between these two is what controls the decay of the temperature, and of course,
this difference is negative as it needs to be for our temperature to decrease.